الطلاق مشاهدينا عبر وسائل التكنولوجيا
بات من الامور المستحدثه ربما اخرها كان
عن طريق الانستقرام لاعب كره القدم
التونسي عمار الجمل اعلن طلاق من زوجته
عبر خاصيه الاستوري في انستجرام ليشعل
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ووسائل الاعلام
لسبب الطلاق بالعقر المعروفه اروى لا تجيد
الطبخ وشؤون المنزل ولا تحترم وجباتها
الزوجيه بحسب عمار وجوه معروفه على
السوشيال ميديا انتقدت تصرف اللاعب بشده
مطالبين اياه بصون العشره معتبرين تصرفات
اهانه كبيره للزوجته عماره الجمل وجه
منتقديه بانه لا يصغي الى الدروس خاصه من
الذين يعتبرهم فاشلين في حياتهم الزوجيه
قال ايضا في اشاره لزوجه البلوجر بان من
ينشر حياه الخاصه باستمرار على السوشيال
ميديا يظهر الا الجانب الايجابي عليه ان
يتحمل بدوره الجانب السلبي لهذه الحياه
ويتوقف عن التزييف كن شفافا
[موسيقى]